welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness has released some
insanely relevatory pieces of footage in
case anyone wasn't planning on seeing
this movie already i guess but a new
promo apparently teasing a certain union
jack and blazard member of the
illuminati also a full one minute scene
of doctor strange's fight with gargantos
so i am going to react to these clips
and then break down the huge details
starting with this promo here we go
steven strange
[Music]
the illuminati will see you now
whoa that's new
wow
marvel studios
it's yellow holy crap 15 seconds and so
much to talk about there okay so there
is a new shot of wanda as she blasts off
of her these stringy ink demons the same
ones that defender strange fights in the
other footage she is here standing on
this platform that looks out over that
same mountain range making me wonder if
this could be the entrance to that dark
hole temple on wounded gore mountain in
the previous spot was a shot of these
demons reflected in her eye now i'm
wondering if they might be a security
measure for this temple for anyone
trying to get into it or to damage it in
some way and defender strange may now be
luring them above the temple away from
this version of wanda allowing her to
fight something or someone else inside
but then our clear shot yet of wanda's
battle in the illuminati citadel showing
what now definitely looks more like
muriel rambo captain marvel but it's the
other warrior despite who now blows her
mind captain carter that is her suit
design from what if and the same union
jack variant shield with the blue on the
outermost circle and now peggy has added
jet pack boosters to her back that tech
along with the suit design of that
variant captain marvel and these
reprogrammed ultron sentries all look
like it could be coming from the same
source making it even more likely that
some variant iron man or ultron infinity
could be among this illuminati lineup i
cannot wait to see hayley at while
reprise her role as peggy carter but it
is not yet confirmed if this is the same
captain carter from what if that captain
carter has had quite a bit of combat
experience in multiverse she pushed a
tentacled hydra monster into a portal
then came out the other end of the
present day she fought as a guardian of
the multiverse against ultron infinity
and then ended her art back in her
variant captain america winter soldier
era timeline i would love if this movie
establishes that history as live action
canon in this peggy's universe i just
know that the animated captain carter
will be a focal character in what if
season 2 and marvel might not want to
tie the character down as a member of
this illuminati either way this rocks
and seeing captain carter in live action
also makes it likely that we might see
jeffrey wright as a live-action who
watches the watcher as well as possibly
a live-action ultron infiniti or any of
the madness from that series now behind
wanda is a new statue that we have not
yet seen looks like a female warrior and
a skirt maybe a statue in honor of
captain carter as one of the founders of
this illuminati panel now following this
is another glimpse at the illuminati
lineup the voice of patrick stewart
charles xavier with a new line we will
see what kind of dr strange you are and
there it is the armrest of the yellow
hover chair so not only is this patrick
stewart returning from the x-men film
franchise they are giving him his iconic
yellow hover chair from the x-men
animated series which is another clue
that the professor x of this movie could
be the one not from the convoluted fox
film franchise like maybe from the
timeline at the end of days of future
past or something but rather from the
animated series which makes sense
considering x-men 97 is coming to disney
plus and if marvel is taking this
approach of animated characters in
live-action form in this film it does
make it likelier that captain carter
could be her virgin from what if now he
says we'll see what kind of doctor
strange you are suggesting this
illuminati panel might have evaluated
other doctor strangers in the past or
maybe even one of their members could be
that supreme strange so let's move on to
the other major release in recent days a
full one minute clip showing doctor
strange's fight with gargantos let's
take a look
[Music]
where is he
oh cool
why was he invisible
i love the music here this music's so
great
[Music]
this is great
this movie's gonna be awesome
[Applause]
now you've probably noticed that new
rockstars is growing we've introduced
new hosts new show formats and the
volume of videos we make every week is
higher than ever and we've got a new
show starting next week that we think
you're going to love the break room is a
daily live show broadcasting from our
actual break room at new rockstars hq in
southern california every weekday
afternoon it'll be covering all the nerd
news from the day reacting to the latest
releases previewing videos you're gonna
see on this channel hosting some special
guests and most important interacting
with you the viewers this live stream
show will feature some familiar new
rockstars faces tom ebeck told jessica
clements producer brandon and you may
even see empty whitney me or even villa
molina on there every once in a while
now this will not be replacing any of
the content you love on new rockstars
it's going to be extra new content in a
new format on the channel the break room
being live is going to let the hosts
interact with you in real time reacting
to your theories disagreeing with your
hot takes and sharing and the joy of
geeking out over our favorite properties
so join new rockstars live in the break
room every weekday here on youtube and
if you missed seeing the show live don't
worry you'll be able to catch the
replays right here on the channel wow
can we just take a moment to appreciate
how fun it is to hear danny elfman's
music return to marvel superhero cinema
he's got such a madcap wow vibe to this
also the heavy horns for gargantos
totally evoked masorgy's night on bald
mountain you remember that one
[Music]
the demonic music from fantasia that you
all conveniently forget about when you
say disney plus will never have a devil
on it strange saves america chavez from
gargantos and i assume this has happened
on the day of christine palmer's wedding
as the weather seems to be the same now
garcanto's interestingly begins this
scene invisible to onlookers only when
strange casts a de-cloaking spell do
they realize the reason vehicles have
been flipped off their axles is a
terrifying squid monster now this is a
lot like how the demonic jackals that
hero summons in moon knight are also
invisible to onlookers and require super
sorcery to perceive the moment gargantos
is decloaked his eye opens and he looks
so pissed like his one eyelid wrinkles
downwards so he looks more like the
two-eyed human face when our brow
furrows major mike wazowski's
single-eyed character design there he
clutches the bust in this threatening
gesture like as if he's strangling it
like back off or i'll crush the girl but
then strange dismantles the pieces of
this bus i like how they ripple outward
and gargantos's eye widens like oh and
later when strange severs his tentacle
you can see the pain in that eye as his
pupil dilates so yeah strange slices
gargantua's tentacle and underneath his
flesh bleeds black i don't know if it'll
look like this in the final film but
this is a bit odd like squid and octopi
don't bleed ink but i did love how in
what if episode 4 reality melted into
comic book ink an aesthetic that seems
to be coming back in this film and so
maybe this beast was crafted from that
sludge now a few possible easter eggs on
the signs here on the bus that gargantos
now throws at them is an ad for la have
a coffee unlock a better day as strange
probably wishes he could do here now
jave means ki something strange uses
christine's watch for in this movie and
if coffee's not your drink of choice the
phone booth has an ad reading the magic
of tea celestial brand and then as
strange conjures a buzzsaw one dude by
the police suv is totally filming all of
this with his phone sam raimi's always
been great about capturing new yorkers
yeah mr square you mess with one of us
you mess with all of us so multiverse of
madness's premiere is less than a week
away and i have been lucky to get
invited to an early press screening on
monday so this will be my final
pre-premiere breakdown of doctor strange
footage whatever else gets revealed in
promos in the days ahead we will be
covering other stuff on this channel
like moon knight and then we will hit
multiverse of madness hard when it opens
to the public next week gentlemen it's
been a pleasure playing with you you can
support new rockstars by checking out
our merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com like this tomb of
the moon god shirt that i'm wearing and
be sure to check out our new daily live
stream the break room starting monday
follow me on instagram and twitter at
eavos following rockstar subscribe to
narc stars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you
[Music]